as long as I am Alive I will not desert
a battle that is mine to fight when you
need me I'll be the easiest man in the
world to find
hey this is William Neff and I'm here at
the Atlas Shrugged three premiere with
Chris Paul aha
Chris the question that's on everybody's
mind who is John Galt I guess the answer
is me this is John Galt speaking those
who have left you are eager to build a
world of freedom what is the most
important message that you want people
to take away from the third installment
of Atlas Shrugged I think the most
important message that I earn ran was
trying to put out in the world is that
individuals are always going to be the
most productive part of any society
which I think sort of anybody along any
party line is going to agree with you
know if you talk to Steven Spielberg
he's an individual who's extremely
creative making things producing films
and I think it's an 1,100 page warning
we can undermine our society and its
history and its future if we continue
where individual is not appreciated to
be able to live their own lives
Dagny we are on strike this is a strike
our minds will quit all you did they had
to withdraw but what about what you left
behind unlike you I don't believe in
abandoning the fight why do you think it
is that the works of Rand have survived
so well over the past 60 years I think
there's a universality I mean a
timelessness to her ideas to just
believing in oneself to working hard for
something you believe in for standing up
for your own you know right to to do
hard work and be rewarded for it they're
very American ideals
here's this woman who had that moment
that really none of us have had which is
she got off the plane or boat and and
there you know she sees the Manhattan
skyline she sees the Statue of Liberty
and she goes I've come to the land of
opportunity what was your greatest
challenge playing one of the most iconic
literary characters of all time is not
to you know f it up you don't want to
you don't want to miss you don't want to
be the guy who's like that's not who
John Galt is like I think he's authentic
I think he's principled I think he's a
guy that's willing to see something
wrong and say no this will not stand and
I think that's what's compelling he's
the archetype he's the hero and all of
them Oliver ends work if you wanted
someone who's seeing the film for the
first time to take something away from
it what would be the message that you
think is most important I think the most
important message would be if you have
something that you really believe in
don't be afraid to buck the trend of the
world don't be afraid to swim against
the current and stand up for your ideas
your thoughts with what you really
believe in it's the beginning